welcome back to gamma unfiltered hosts
by me josh smith and today we're joined
by the queen
of netflix slash the new queen
of the arthur tales it's catherine
langford
hey hey
babe how are you
i'm good thank you given the
circumstances how are you
good you know we're we're living we're
thriving and the exciting thing is is
that the new show
is on the horizon because it's such a
massive production
what was the most testing aspect of this
for you
i had to learn sword fighting horse
riding
and i had to come up with a new english
dialect so
kind of learning all that and then yeah
learning this vast skill set
and then on top of that being able to
maintain it for the shoot was definitely
a challenge but it was also something
really nice and it kind of made me learn
a lot and sort of
how to maintain that and also just how
to
try and keep giving the same top level
of performance
every day were there like times when you
really pushed yourself and you're like
what wtf i can't believe that she just
doubled
uh you know you're in the cold for such
a long time like hypothermia i went into
hypothermia a couple of times
on camera if you're cold your lips will
will shake
and so really having to to learn like
how to breathe like really like
controlled breathing
just so you could get a couple of
seconds where your lips weren't shaking
i was thinking to um when i was watching
this and how nimway's
class is a witch and how like labeling
to women
is still so reductive even today
i was thinking about that and i was like
well we've come so far obviously because
this is like the middle ages
but like but like but then in other ways
that sense of like the need to label
what a woman is and who she is
is still very prevalent in our society
how have you
navigated that in your own life have you
ever felt like
people tried to label you and you tried
to like
maybe sometimes play up to it and then
rebel against it how has that
been for you i was one of those kids
where i never
fit into a box like i was this
athlete like i loved athletics and i
could do sport but then i was
like also kind of like girly
and i liked makeup but i didn't want to
be a part of that popular girl group
and i was also a nerd and i also liked
music so there were all these different
boxes that
i checked but also at the same time like
i just didn't fit into one of them
perfectly
feeling free and doing what makes you
feel free is so important and i think
that's what makes people special you
know
do you ever feel that people still try
to put you into a box
i definitely remember earlier on in my
career that being talked about i think i
was about like
18 or something and i did a casting
workshop and the casting director came
in
he was from like a main studio and he
basically said
these words of like character actress
leading actress like they were two
separate things like if you're a leading
actress you're one thing if you're a
character actress you're another thing
i remember just being so kind of
confused
by that when you think back to the you
growing up in
perth what kind of things were you going
through at that time that you possibly
struggled with i mean i mean we all have
ups and downs and i probably can't like
list like one or two specific because i
think it it it ranged
you know like school i didn't know where
i
fit in i i didn't know which books i was
supposed to be in and i actually
remember
wait i have to i have to share this i
remember um
we had like this magazine we had a
couple of like these girls magazines and
they would have pictures of celebrities
with a quote
i had this picture of scarlett johansson
who was saying you know
in essence or something along the lines
of like just be yourself and i remember
i was 12 and i looked at this and i just
went
but who am i like tell me tell me who
who who i'm supposed to be should i like
dress like this and then i'm
and then i'm that person should i like
dress like this and then be this person
so
i think a lot of it was and still you
know trying to figure out
who you are less now about where i fit
because like
to hell with that i'll make my own box
but like
you know like figuring out who you are
yes
yes what has it been like for you to
come to terms
with your own skin your own body your
own beauty
you know i i get the feeling that when
you're younger beauty or being beautiful
is equated to looking like someone else
you know it's it's a lot of what other
people have to say
and over the past couple of years i i
feel like i've learned that the more you
can own who you are
and the more confident you are in
yourself the more you're able to
recognize
the beauty that you have within but also
appreciate it within within other people
and that and that to me is the true
essence of being beautiful
can you remember some turning points in
that or some changes in that
there's this there's this moment that i
had probably a couple of years ago
and i think i was like 21
21 22 like around around that sort of
age
um where i was already considered an
adult
but there was like this second stage of
evolution where i felt like i was coming
into
my womanhood for a better word yeah
you know at that point you you really
own
um a lot more about your body but i
think there's a lot more
in your confidence and who you are as a
person and maybe i had to do that a
little
more quickly because like when i travel
i don't have my mom i don't i don't
really have anyone around me so
you have to really take that ownership
of yourself and kind of like
mother yourself i guess like i but not
in that way but you have to give
yourself the pep talk you have to look
at yourself in the mirror and say like
okay we're good to go today we can do
this or if you're tired you're the one
telling yourself like come on girl we
can do this you can have that vacation
after we're done yeah like because i
guess like because if you had when you
were younger and you were swimming and
you had this like great faith in your
body as well
i actually do you think that maybe this
is just a question
but like i was just thinking do you
think that having that
such a strong body image from early on
has set you up
to be able to cope with this crazy
entertainment industry where body image
is still a topic that we even have to
still talk about
to be honest i don't think so no you
know because
i in a way i think it almost made me
think about it
on more levels you know i like on
one hand i feel really grateful to have
grown up doing sport and and growing up
with a value in my body's capabilities
and not just focusing on my body's
appearance
but also at the same time you know
growing up as a girl in sport
you're also you know you face a bunch of
other
critiques and criticisms of like you
can't fit into this or
you know your body isn't doesn't look
this way or you look
too strong um not that there is any such
thing
you know um so you kind of i think it's
i i think it may be just the same level
as
as everyone else but obviously from from
different points of view
that being said it i am really grateful
to have maintained that
um respect for you know my body's
capabilities and i think
that's been important with me coming
into this industry in a way because i've
heard from so many girls and i was
so surprised to hear from so many girls
and also now i think about it like
just boys and other people saying you
know
just enjoying seeing someone who looks
like them
um and i realize how how harsh
social media can be when everything is
so perfect and put together and magazine
ready
i want young girls to see that not only
can they be strong and not only can they
can they fight but they can do it in a
way that honors them and honors their
body and
also honors their gender because this is
all about
her discovering her power and leaning
into her power
learning how to harness it which is
something we all have to do as humans
as we go through our lives for you what
have been some turning points
in discovering and realizing your own
power
wow i feel like that's such a that's a
lifelong journey
but definitely i think i mean for me one
of the biggest
lessons i think i've ever had is that
moment when um
i got into drama school after three
years of auditioning
and i got these two projects to go and
test for so i turned down drama school
and went to test for these two projects
in the us and the uk
and basically didn't get either of them
so
i came back not being able to go to
school
without a job and had to call all my
like bar jobs and stuff like that back
and it was that moment where i was i was
just at rock bottom like i didn't know
what
i was going to do if i was meant to do
this if it was even possible
um and i kept auditioning and it was a
couple of weeks after
that that my first project which turned
out to be
13 reasons why i came through so that
for me was a huge
kind of turning point i think and it's
it's
it's crazy and i'm very like grateful
and thankful that it
all worked out and young catherine kept
doing her thing if i was young catherine
who hit that rock bottom and i was on
the zoom culture right now
what would you want to say to her
that's such a tricky question i mean i
think all i needed
to do was just like believe in myself
and i think anyone
at any age you go through ups and downs
um and you go through doubts and
you know not knowing what you're
supposed to do and you come to a lot of
crossroads throughout life and
i guess the best thing you can do is
just keep going and listen to your gut
and if something feels right just just
keep going for it and something will
something will happen obviously you're
about to become
a l'oreal global ambassador which is
like
so nuts in itself and you're becoming
this woman of worth
that's what they call it what does
being a woman of worth mean
to you your your self-worth
is is predominantly up to you and and
how you value yourself and
and how you see yourself but you know
funny we were talking about
friends and whatnot i feel like you're
worth
is also whether you like it or not it
can be determined by other people as
well and influenced by other people
for better or worse you know being in
this this industry that i'm
in uh you are in a sense your own
commodity and so your sense of value and
worth is
is valued by different people um in so
many different ways
and sometimes i think that can make you
question it especially if you're younger
you know and
you're still trying to figure out who
you are
and what you want to do whenever you
felt the most
worth it would you say that's such a
good question
um i feel like you're always worth it
and not that you're always feeling 100
you know like no one ever feels 100 110
um but you're always worth it and i
think everyone always deserves to feel
that
i was thinking about you know when you
got nominated for your golden globe and
that was during the time's up movement
and there's
there's definitely this amazing
incredible
sisterhood that's in your industry now
how
have you leaned in to sisterhood
in your not let's say with your own
sister but sisters
in general that idea of sisterhood have
you leaned into that in your own life
during different times
well i feel really lucky i think
throughout the course of my life so far
to have a strong female presence whether
it is family or
friends or in the form of a teacher
mentor coaches
that moment at the golden globes where
which for me was really special you know
it's my it's my
first ever golden globes nomination um
first nomination like it was it was
so exciting and then to connect that to
um
uh the time's up movement uh and
sort of you know i i it kind of took
place in the form of getting this call
from a woman that i really admired it
was it was reese witherspoon who reached
out to me initially and i was on the
phone with her
and i was like oh my gosh like this this
person like
wants to welcome me in and then we have
this meeting before
the golden globes um the day before to
kind of discuss all the sort of
intricacies of what we were gonna do um
and i just walked into this room of like
25 of the most experienced
and and like inspiring incredible
actresses and
it was something where i felt very like
starstruck but at the same time i also
felt
very welcomed and open um
and that and that was really
overwhelming like i got a bit teary when
i was talking to some of them because
it you know especially growing up like
in this industry you hear these things
that are like
you know um you know women are this way
or women in that way and
it just felt so far from the truth you
know i think that
women are so powerful and every i mean
everyone as a human being
has power within them um but i think
through history
women in particular as a group have sort
of faced these obstacles that are very
specific to our gender
you know we're such an intimidable force
together
and when we when we truly support each
other and and
stand together it only serves to lift
all of us up
has there been times where maybe for
instance people haven't necessarily
given you that respect and you've stood
up for it and
made sure you've had your voice heard
you're so eager
to please in the sense that you want to
do your job to the best ability that you
can and all these like
stories that you hear about being
difficult or whatever you're just always
very at least i am very you know
conscious of
i i don't want to be difficult but also
i think growing up and having experience
and having other
women to to talk to and get reference
from you
also need to stand up for yourself if
something isn't
isn't right which often it's it's not
often everything is fine
but i do feel like maybe maybe also
sometimes it's
difficult like as a young person or a
younger person
and maybe also as a woman there's still
a part of me
that recognizes that even if i do say
something regardless of how
eloquent or logical it will be that you
always feel like there may still
be that that um i don't know
that there is always i guess someone
like looking that
at that or or whatever um
but for for the most part you know i
mean just speaking to my last project
which was cursed
um you know that was a really long long
long shoot
like i said like one day we had out we
were shooting in a forest and it was
completely waterlogged
and like 10 people went home and then we
had an inadvertent
snow day in the middle of summer in
wales like all these really random
things that happened
i actually had like members of the crew
who you know if if they
needed something or whatever they would
come to me and they'd be like hey like
um uh hey like uh do you need this or
they were just there was this open
dialogue where like i felt respected
as an individual not as like i don't
know
not not being sort of talked down to or
sort of like
sweet talk like you know when people
call you like sweetie or honey or
or any of those kind of things and i
think but i think that's that respect to
a degree was
also earned because i had to do a couple
of stunts and i think some of the stunt
guys were really impressed and some of
the
camera rigs were really impressed um
because i would like
complete masochists like i would stay in
that water as cold as it was until we
got
shot i'd be like jumping off of things
and the guys were like all right
all right like you you know there was
that respect that was earned from
doing my job and that's what i
appreciated
everyone's voice is equal and and
everyone has their own experience to
talk from
so in that sense it's like everyone's
opinion is
valid and important to be listened to do
you think the younger you
who didn't feel like she fitted into a
box
um and didn't really feel like she
fitted in like you were saying earlier
do you think that she would be so proud
of you
sitting here today i don't know young
catherine was pretty
pretty tough pretty tough she'd probably
she'd probably be like you're doing all
right
no i i you know this like
i like i said like i grew up in in perth
which is a small city in australia and
i loved it and it's one of the most
magical places on earth for me
but doing this like it didn't feel like
tangible let alone a possibility for so
many years so
it's so incredible even the fact that
i'm sitting here
and able to talk to you about any of
this is
i'm just i'm just so grateful and i'm
always going to be grateful for that
because i
truly like love all of this thanks for
taking the time out speak to me
thank you so much you too and thank you
for the time this has been really
nice and uplifting so thank you
you